yeah to be honest it's sort of tense i
mean it's not that i uh
like check the games for hours uh yeah
in the evening so
i don't know but the brief look was uh
yeah was such so yeah from outside it
seems super complex in any case you've
won the the match with one and a half so
tomorrow there's no typing for you
two three days what are you expecting to
do the next few days uh before the
fourth round
yeah i don't know actually so i mean
first of all i mean it was only
i mean it was it was only in the taxi uh
whenever i
that actually there is a free day after
yeah after the time breaks
uh so there is no plan really i thought
of going uh going back to sochi like to
to the city maybe i mean i have a walk i
mean to
you know to look at the sea again and
stuff yeah we'll see in general yeah
having two two three this is a bit too
much i mean one is nice but
two yeah i mean this place is uh i mean
it's nice but it's not that large here i
mean
there are not too many things to do and
the casino is also way too close which
is also dangerous so uh
yeah we'll see